speaking of resets you're from illinois
right yes
illinois new
safety act yeah okay funny name where
where you can't even protect your own
property you know trespassers can come
in and camp on your property on your
front porch and the police will not do
anything yeah
i mean what is going on they're
attacking property rights values across
the board in illinois you will own
nothing and you will be happy see this
is a good point the safety act do you
hear about this
they're saying like as you said the
police won't respond to trespassers on
your property and they're going to
eliminate cash bail for most criminal
offenders murder
even murder okay but you guys realize
you're talking to a guy who's from
california
hold my beer
it's already happened here huh i mean i
can go on and on you're you're like oh
the good old days don't let them do it
to you but this is another example
you're talking this is
chicago in the
suburbs dictating to the rest of the
state yeah
well look i mean we have
i always tell the story about
people who haven't been to california
recently you see the pictures of the
homeless that you see the pictures of
the nuttiness in san francisco and you
see the pictures in la and all the all
the popular places but those places have
always had homeless people it's just
that they've
they're 10 or 15x
where you didn't have homeless people
were in the rest of the state or if you
did they were kind of your traditional
hobo kind you know you have onesies two
z's five maybe well let's let's let's
real quick let's uh let's break this
down hobo means homeward bound and it's
a reference to people moving
right so that makes us be sleeping
outside but they're leaving
vagrants i think are just you know
derelict individuals who mill about
vagabonds are see are travelers and then
a bum i think is somebody who doesn't
work
so
you know you get we got to make sure we
yeah those terms right right and that
but that's traditionally what you had
hobos but you just had a few a few of
each one of that category you just said
you know like in my home city you know
65 000 people
and you know you just have a handful of
people and you'd please go out there
work with them and churches would take
care of them
and so i always tell people this it was
it was not that long ago it was
i think it was 2015.
i have a church across the street from
my house
and
there were two homeless people that
started living out there
and but that was it there was no in the
whole city that was the only ones i mean
there were a handful of others that
people were in and out of homes there
was places that they could get to
and i remember all my neighbors saying
oh my god can you these people are
living right there across the street
and they were people were shocked
and they went to the church said look
you can't have these people living
across the street the church says well
look we're a home for you know we're a
church so we got to you know help these
people
well then the two turned into six and
the six turned into twelve and then the
church said no solicitation put you know
so homeless people were gone
from the church
and then but they didn't go very far
and now in in my in my home city 65 000
people what started with just a handful
of homeless okay we now have estimated
somewhere between five and 700
in my home city wow
but that's in every single city across
california so i call it it's like zombie
apocalypse we are welcoming all these
people here they have their own
governments
and so it's like stockholm syndrome
right i remember how i just gave the
story 2015. everybody's oh my god
there's two homeless people across the
street
to now there's zombies everywhere and
nobody does anything
i mean i've got literally
a football field away from me
and where i live we've got a whole
homeless encampment i mean i i can't my
kids my girls can't walk over to the
little the little market mini market
because they gotta go through a homeless
camp so i made this point i think it was
memorial day we went to the movies and
there was not a soul in sight the movie
theater was empty the arcade machines
had been removed from it this is a big
shopping center in frederick
and i'm walking around and i'm looking
around i'm like where where are the
people
no nobody's here nobody's out there's a
pool hall it's empty where'd everybody
go there's an ice cream shop
closed and it said we're closed due to
short staff and i was like where are the
people i recently went to um
what city is i can't remember the name
of the city i know it's in west virginia
and there's a diner at noon on a weekend
saying closed martinsburg martinsburg
that's the one closed due to short staff
and then i was just like where is
everyone and then ian made a good point
he goes a lot of more homeless people
popping up and i was like man is that
what's happening
people aren't working anywhere they're
losing their homes they can't afford it
anymore and that's why the homeless
population is increasing so much
i think what what at least what you see
in california and we're getting them
from all over the country
and it's really sad because
a lot of them are a product of of
of meth
methamphetamines oh man i started
watching breaking bad you know their
minds are all about it now
yeah
it's pretty bad i mean they're
you feel bad because there's not really
nothing
these people are never going to be able
to function in life and they just kind
of fall like i i hate calling them
zombies but i don't really know what
else to call them they just kind of
follow and they have leaders meth heads
and um yeah but a lot of them aren't
even doing meth anymore i don't think
crackheads yeah they're just gone hunter
bidens well heroin fentanyl whatever it
is yeah you know we got a big problem
across the whole country with this well
it's a plague well if you look at
homelessness a lot of it is usually
correlated to it not just drug addiction
but a mental health crisis and i think
that mental health crisis is getting
worse and worse especially by the
numbers when you look at depression
self-harm suicide those numbers have
been going up dramatically how do you
how do you deal with this type of
situation and you know who do we blame
do we blame big pharma for the opioid
epidemic do we blame china for the
fentanyl that makes it worse do we blame
the fast food industry that's creating
an uh a a poor mental health do we blame
social media that's also creating poor
mental health do you
blame legalization of marijuana across
the whole country do you blame
you know i mean you could go on down the
list but the drug use across the board
contributes significantly to the mental
health issues because it does create
damage to the brain and the functioning
of a good segment of that population
alcohol though
yeah and alcohol i think substantially
worse than pot yeah but prohibition
didn't work you know and we were like
let's repeal that amendment that didn't
make sense it's funny that we i'm
surprised you know learning about
american history that they actually were
actually able to get a constitutional
amendment
just to get rid of alcohol yeah that's
crazy i think it's crazy that you know
marijuana is still illegal in some
states but but doctors could prescribe
legalized heroin and get people addicted
and hooked on for the rest of their
lives that's a problem right there that
deserves to be called out and yes
marijuana is being genetically
engineered there's a whole bunch of
frankenstein marijuana that's really bad
especially for children but we we can't
start with prohibition it never worked
it never has worked but but there is
something to say about how society has
failed most people and most people are
now becoming homeless or poor more than
ever yeah i think what you say i mean
all of these issues that we're talking
about there's there all of them to some
degree
matter
but but the challenge that we have in
california
is that you know
i always tell people stop if you don't
want bears stop feeding the bears
right i mean you you have to you have to
admit you have a problem and stop and
and we're getting more and more and more
of them and there's so many things that
have to be done to handle the problem
but it is i mean look nobody every time
i get on a plane i just when i when i
left california the other day
before i got stuck in in dallas and then
teleported to the secret meeting with
with president trump at the golf course
before all that it could have been your
evil twin though
could have been or good twin are you the
evil one but continue
but every time i fly i get oh i used to
hey you used to be my congressman back
in the day but you know i left at texas
like five years ago or three years ago i
mean every time it's people that are
still have business in california or
whatever but they've moved their
headquarters to a different state wow
well the exodus is happening in illinois
too
maybe it's a self-correcting problem you
let them run amok and go crazy for long
enough and people are going to be like
i'm out how long before illinois goes
bankrupt i don't know how long i mean
can the state go bankrupt
well biden will give him money he'll
find a way they'll find a way to just
pump money into the system and keep keep
the zombie state hopping along well
remember the so
in california you know we're going to be
all green right yet we're we're not
building any new ways to produce power
in mass in fact we shut down a nuclear
power plant we were talking about
nuclear a few minutes ago and then they
were going to shut down our last two
reactors that are still supplying 10 of
our power so i don't know if everybody's
paying attention but you couldn't charge
your car the other night
if you were in california you had to and
the governor sent a message to
everybody's phone saying turn off your
power now do you see the colorado when
the thermostats couldn't be changed
oh no i didn't energy crisis your
thermostat stuck at 78. well that's if
you sign up for that program right but
people this is the thing they come to
you and they say do you want to sign up
for our smart saver program it's 100
bucks off your bill per year
sure sounds like all right have a nice
day and then all of a sudden you can't
change your thermostat it's not like
people knew they were signing up for
that yeah
but now they but they until they feel
pain so now newsome wants to run for
president he feels pain
there's we're on the verge of blackouts
all the time
and it's not just because of you
everybody says oh my god it's global
warming it's like no you idiots it
always gets hot in california during the
summer i mean it's not unusual for there
to be you know big spikes in in terms of
it doesn't happen in florida you know
you know what it is you're right it
doesn't i was in california during the
drought in like 2015
and ain't nobody stopped showering they
were like everybody got to limit your
water use and i knew people who were
like yeah but not me and that was the
mentality of almost every single person
they're all running their long hot
showers being like i don't care yeah but
the drought is so if so do you now
you're getting into my wheelhouse now
it's how i actually got in politics was
because this crazy water issue
so you realize that
like l.a san francis san francisco is
actually a desert nobody thinks of it as
a desert san francisco san francisco is
a desert but what the delta water is
what keeps it alive no what keeps it
alive actually was the the founding
fathers of the city realized they needed
some really fresh good clean water
they went into yosemite national park
dammed up a valley not as big as
yosemite valley but one that was a small
mirror image of it just over the
mountain range they dammed it up it's a
dam called hetch hetchy
they dammed it up they piped the water
sorry how do you spell that hetch hetchy
h-e-t-c-h
easy enough yep
yeah oh hatchet yeah let's pull up the
map
continue perfect yeah so if you if you
keep that map up
so back in the turn around the turn of
the century i'm talking about 1900 now
the
city of san francisco figured out hell
we don't have any water here we got to
do something because you can't drink the
salt water in the bay right yeah so they
they built that dam created that lake
and they pipe the water all the way over
to san francisco
all right that's where san francisco
gets its water wow now as the rest of
the state developed
all these water projects were built
and there's actually plenty of water in
the state you just have to move it
around you have to keep it in the wet
years
and you have to move it around because
it's not uncommon for california to go
through everybody says like you said
there was a drought in 15. yeah we have
droughts like all the time like you
deserve you have a laser desert yeah
you'll have you'll have two wet wet
years you'll have four dry years you
have one wet year but but my point to
say all this is that
is it this is a man
made created crisis like the people of
california knew
that like when we had people with brains
they knew hey we better build some
nuclear power plants if we're going to
have 40 million people living here we
better build nuclear power plants clean
easy they work and in fact the last what
i was saying about payne
newsom now after republicans the few
republicans that are left including our
delegation said idiot
you're going to run the state of out of
power he finally acquiesced and said i'm
going to come in and save the nuclear
power plant not talking about how he was
the one that was going to shut it down
in the first place and the same thing as
water until people run out of water into
what you said tim that like they
actually don't have any water coming out
of the tab i've seen it there won't be
there won't be any pain nobody will pay
the price and they won't change their
methods of operation they just leave
well the conservative people leave well
everybody does even the liberal people
the liberal people vote for policies and
vote for people like newsome burn to the
ground and then go this sucks i'm
leaving i'm going to montana i'm going
to utah then they bring their policies
with them yeah and then it happens all
over again
it it's it's a cultural problem a lot of
this everything i think we're facing is
all cultural issues there are there
there is a sect of people right now and
it's mostly the the democrats the biden
supporters
they only care about saying what is
socially acceptable so of course they
repeat what they see on tv they believe
every single hoax and they vote for
policies that destroy everything so long
as the mob
they agree with the mob they're content
to just watch everything burn
these people
you know i feel like they've always been
here they've always been around but with
social media they've been trapped in a
spiral where they're all just chasing
each other it's a mexican standoff of
cancer culture so you have people who
are brave enough to be like
i don't agree with that i'm not going to
agree with that and then they get mad at
you saying you're not agreeing with the
consensus reality so you're a bad guy
you're an extremist exactly that's the
white house you're an extremist so what
ends up happening is they say the
acceptable thing is that nuclear power
is bad the acceptable thing is that coal
power plants are bad then you end up
with no power doesn't matter they said
right thing good thing was said
therefore we good then the grid
collapses everyone suffers and they flee
to your state and they say the same
exact things one by one just gutting and
destroying that's what i'm worried about
with texas
look um mad respect to joe rogan you
know he recently said vote republican
did you guys hear this when they were
like what do you tell these people whose
businesses were
shut down and he's like what republican
and they laugh
and people point out it's good that joe
moved to texas you know because he
opposes that stuff but what people don't
understand is that joe is surrounded by
wealth and industry and the people who
will follow him for him and not for
politics for political reasons are going
to bring liberal policies elon musk
brings the gigafactory to i think to
austin and everyone's like oh that's
great elon musk he's fleeing california
whoo and it's like and all of the people
who lived in california working for him
two to one it's democrats it's liberal
voters coming to texas
now i think there still is good news
because it seems like more anti-woke
anti-cult people are moving to texas and
it's going to help keep the state
red
and you have the rio grande valley which
is has turned red so i think it'll be
okay well that would actually dilute the
cults that was one of the things i was
gonna
i think the the mexican vote in this
country and i specifically say you could
actually use the kind of the larger term
hispanic but it's really the mexican
boat that's in texas in california
arizona those places if that vote
actually begins to shift and it doesn't
have to shift very much and if you if
you remember in 2016 when trump won
remember the fake news had created this
whole narrative that
trump was going to you know get rid of
all the hispanics they were all going to
be kicked out of the country remember
that yeah but he posted that taco bell
picture you know i didn't play for a
second well
but a lot of people did i mean it was it
was kind of a hard time because i felt
bad like like small kids that my wife's
a schoolteacher and i remember hearing
the stories about little kids actually
thought that they were gonna you know
that trump was like gonna come and you
know get them and and send them back
even though they were born in the united
states but that's the kind of damage you
talk about that this can do to to young
people these images but do you know that
in in the only growth area that i saw
in the electorate in california in 18
and in 20 was with mexican-american
voters if you were working
mexican-american those those people and
actually working any anyone they're
moving republicans they're they're
they're shifting not quickly but they're
shifting we saw it on the rio grande
valley where you're not shifting
uh anybody who's college educated
doesn't matter what color what letter
you use you know as your pronouns
you
are going to be you're shifting left
well one of the things on the exodus
the governor of new york says hey
republicans leave new york get out of
here we don't want you here yeah that
was amazing
in florida
there's now an 800 000 republican voter
advantage and it used to be the other
way around yeah
well us and rumble we're in sarasota
florida the new free speech capital true
socials in florida sarasota so is rumble
tim cass should move down to sarasota
florida that's what i've been telling
tim i visited sarasota i visited the
headquarters in rumble at rumble i was
like this is a great place tim got all
right all right yeah you guys should
move there we'll need a that'd be fun
and i could come on the show all the
time we would need uh if the city can
provide some kind of like grant so that
we can relocate 30 plus employees and
build new infrastructure we otherwise
can tax incentives we'll just talk to
you know uh ron he'll be like hey ron
hook it up
desantis the weather man this is the
problem it's not that bad oh i'm not
that bad i lived in the redlands no
income tax yeah you lived in no
individual income tax yes you live deep
inside of the thing you got to be by the
beach where the breeze is it's cool it's
fun it's it's great it's 100 degrees
with maximum humidity all the time no
miami air conditioning
sarasota's beautiful i loved it there i
thought the same thing so you know when
i was in dc like california gets hot
where i'm from i'm from the big
agricultural valley
and i mean we're at 105 you know we got
111 the other day
and
but i've never been hotter outside of
when i was in iraq a few times which
colonel harvey lived there for five or
six years so he can at least he could
tell you about real hot
but
but in dc i mean if it would be
in the 90s 95 with that nasty humidity
with no breeze
and like that's what you'll see
sometimes in miami but you're exactly
right i just think i've been shocked at
how even when i i thought oh man i'm
gonna the humidity is gonna suck in in
sarasota but there's always like this
breeze that comes off the gulf yeah it's
amazing i'm a big fan we shouldn't be
talking about sarasota because all
you're we're going to have too many
people too many people are going to move
and they're already moving in i talked
to some locals that live there they're
like everyone's moving in everyone's
taking all the properties so damn
yuppies are coming in here hey i'll tell
you what we'll build you a studio in our
office okay every state the average high
in january is 72.
perfect the average high in april mays
82 then 87 90 in june 91 in july 91 in
august 90 in september 86 in august
that's not that's not that different
than here that's very different from
here the average high in january here is
like 35.
i i still i'm a big florida man i love
florida i'm very biased in my uh you
know love affair why don't you why don't
politically i like florida why don't you
do i'm just well it's a person we're
just throwing stuff at the wall i'm just
this is just this is it's a battleground
it's a purple state it's gonna go either
way we need all the resources down in
florida we should build a winter cast
castle exactly just in october uh so in
in was it oh i don't even have december
pulled up i can teleport but you can
mine read yeah that's exactly what i was
so november to february is what we're
based in florida and then we come back
exactly and then you detoxify you sweat
out all the toxins from your body and i
i sweat every single day skating luke
we're skating out there today all right
and we're and i'm covered in sweat and
luke's sitting there hunched over eating
a stromboli with pepperoni i was doing
pull-ups right before that all right i
did i did a little working out today so
i really came out with a balance board
and then he pulled out a stromboli and
just slouched it down and was like and i
was working out in the gym you can check
the surveillance cameras anyway uh not
going too personal because we got to do
super chats really yeah and
questions i really wanted to ask you uh
but you got to go to sarasota and then
we'll and we'll just we'll just do it
right here right now um i really want to
talk about the intelligence committee
because i hear so many rumors just about
being a part of this this kind of
committee i'm hearing about people being
scared of losing their clearances i
heard even diane feinstein in 2014
talked about how the cia was spying on
this committee how was it uh you know
being a part of this committee what was
going on can you tell us your
experiences were you being spied on was
there's
what was going what was going on on the
inside you know at
i actually had the
i'm probably the only person or very few
people on the planet who can actually
say this
i went from the very best job in the
world
and within a matter of just a few months
to the very worst job in the world
okay so
i was i was having uh you know it was it
was tough work but it was it was
rewarding work you get to work with
patriots like colonel harvey
um a lot of the folks i worked with it
was very bipartisan you never heard from
the house intelligence committee
until it was a sent until you got to the
point of you know if there was a
terrorist attack or some international
issue because
you know people didn't even really want
to serve on the intelligence committee
because it was hard work you had to do a
lot if you actually took it seriously
you had to do a lot a lot of travel it
wasn't to great places you know except
when harvey and i were in
vienna that one time yeah yeah
but
so
but then overnight trump wins
and then they turn it into
that you know everybody's a russian
agent everybody's russian disinformation
so it went from the best job to the to
the worst job i mean i went under you
know because i had to sit there and take
all their [ __ ] for year after year i
mean look i'm still crazy i'm not even
congress in congress anymore and i mean
look they're still attacking you know my
former staff i mean cash patel i mean
they put him in a damn warrant the other
day with his you know that story that we
were talking about about what i bart was
he said
the breitbart story that he was in so
well yeah i mean there's still i mean
every day this this it's like this they
put you in a story about a secret
meeting with donald trump on a golf
course yeah was there was there any more
retribution that you faced for speaking
out against what you knew was wrong and
what you were
right all along about
i mean look there's still
you have i mean like this is this is i
was getting you know
why did i leave why did i leave congress
it's because the flow the free flow of
information the internet is shut down
we're trying to create a beachhead to
open it back up
i mean it's that same and the way that i
realized it is is after the 2020
election
i thought to myself you know after you
know parlor got canceled all that we
talked about earlier but another
important point is
how could it be that you still had over
half of america at that point according
to polls that i'd seen right after the
election that believed that trump and
republicans
had something to do with russia they
don't know what
but they had somebody with russia and
that's when i said oh my god like how
did this happen like i spent four years
debunking this whole damn thing it's a
total hoax
and you still had half of america who
didn't know about it and who believed it
and the counter-buying story was
censored and the hunter biden story was
censored yeah yeah
is there anything that you were you were
you know a part of the committee that
that you were able to preview uh get
information about that you knew
everyone else was wrong about other than
just the the whole russian gate
well other than harvard i know china we
were doing a lot on china
identifying
what china was doing in technology
espionage pushing that china was a real
threat and that was
that was before trump thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
monday through friday at 8 pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the tim cast irl podcast and
there's a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
monday through friday at 8pm and we'll
see you all there